[Music]
on this wednesday night the mandatory
vaccine policy in canada
federal employees told to get their
shots if they want to be paid anyone who
lies on their attestation will face
severe consequences plus two doses will
be the ticket to board a plane or train
in canada
under pressure doctors and nurses demand
an urgent remedy for the kova 19
healthcare crisis i know that you know
there's a bunch of other families who
are going through the same thing we are
and it
breaks my heart as alberta patients bear
the brunt of cancelled surgeries how
badly is canada fumbling on its carbon
emission goals and what can be done to
get on track
and a killer discovery about killer
whales the little-known orcas hunting
big game off bc's coast
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill good
evening and thank you for joining us
work and travel plans are about to
change for some unvaccinated canadians
the federal government has revealed
details of its new mandatory vaccine
policy public servants are required to
declare their vaccination status by the
end of october or be forced to take
unpaid leave as early as november 15th
and all travelers 12 and older must be
fully vaccinated by october 30th to
board planes and trains the vaccination
information will be tracked and audited
and managers can ask for proof at any
time but as abigail beeman reports in
our top story tonight the new policy has
triggered frustration at one of the
country's biggest unions
mandatory vaccines for federal employees
a promise launched on the eve of the
election campaign wednesday the
re-elected liberals dropped more details
the bottom line
proof of vaccination will be required by
no later than the end of this month for
all federal employees public servants
have until october 29th to submit an
attestation not actual proof of
vaccination and those who don't will be
placed on administrative leave
without pay
as early as november 15th it doesn't
apply to everybody in coming into a
federal workplace the public service
alliance of canada supports a vaccine
policy but has concerns including a lack
of consultation sending us a draft
document 24 hours before the
announcement is made
that's not meaningful consultation
not at all so i am terribly disappointed
that the prime minister didn't follow
through on his promise to consult with
unions these mandates are going to push
us to a high enough degree of
vaccination
that our economy can continue to be open
our kids can continue to go to school
but will they the government estimates
the new rules apply to 267 000 public
service employees including the rcmp
plus they're asking crown corporations
canada post for example to mirror the
policy and say they're working with
federally regulated employers to do the
same that represents another million
people the chief of the defense staff is
issuing a vaccine directive wednesday
for all canadian armed forces members
and the second piece starting october
30th everyone 12 and up must be fully
vaccinated to board a plane or train in
canada with cruise ship passengers to
follow it's not clear what happens if an
employee picks a drawn-out unpaid leave
it will probably lead its way into a
termination although it's very
interesting that that's not what the
federal government said today but we can
certainly read between the lines the
city of toronto just announced unpaid
suspension will be followed by
termination come december 13th for those
employees who don't provide proof of
vaccination
nationally there will be some
accommodations made including on
religious or medical grounds exceedingly
narrow
specific
and to be honest somewhat onerous to
obtain
actual proof of vaccination a vaccine
passport remains clunky at best with a
patchwork of systems across the country
the prime minister continues to promise
a national vaccine certificate to make
things easier especially for travel but
wednesday trudeau didn't have any new
specifics to share on timing
robin abigail beeman in ottawa thanks
abigail
healthcare workers say they are under so
much strain they're past their breaking
points two of canada's largest medical
professional organizations held an
emergency summit and say without urgent
help from ottawa canadian health care
will crumble jamie morocco reports
the last 19 months have been anything
but easy for doctors and nurses inside
this montreal icu we've had a lot of
deaths and we've had a lot of young
patients die and it's hard to it's hard
it's frankly hard to see these people
die add to this staffing and bed
shortages we scramble and we do our best
to try and accommodate every patient for
almost two years the pandemic has
highlighted the ever growing cracks in
canadian health care in toronto these
nurses say they are underpaid and
overworked
we cannot carry triple quadruple
workloads
and keep you safe in alberta the icus
are overflowing exhausted physicians
have been begging the province for help
yes beds have been opened up perhaps the
monitor's been attached to them but
there are not the staff available to
care for those patients the federal
government has a plan in place to send
assistance but members of the canadian
medical association and the canadian
nurses association worry ottawa is
ignoring the bigger picture
asking for funding for staff and a
federal system to track the shortages we
have been telling them for years these
are issues we've been working in an
environment of austerity understaffing
inadequate resources but what we see is
instead of politicians actually owning
this government's owning this problem
they bounce the issue back and forth
ministry health says there is more to do
but human resources ultimately is a
provincial responsibility
in quebec as it begins to enforce its
health care worker vaccine mandate next
week more staff could be lost it's
like a wild roller coaster
to be honest
a lot of a lot of workers have left it's
turning to local paramedics to fill the
gap a short-term solution
to an unprecedented situation jamie
rocker global news toronto
eight critical care nurses from the
canadian armed forces are now in
edmonton to help the province fight kova
19. the number of new daily infections
appears to be stabilizing but intensive
care units are still operating at twice
their normal size and it's come at an
incredible cost 8 500 surgeries have
been canceled in alberta since late
august heather york's west shows us the
toll it's taken he's hoping okay some
days are tougher than others
four-year-old xavier mature has epilepsy
at nine months old he suffered a seizure
that nearly cost him his life currently
we're not able to control his epilepsy
with medications
so in order to
get rid of the seizures
they need to resect two parts of his
brain
and currently we were waiting for that
surgery but the preschooler is one of
hundreds of pediatric patients to have
had their surgeries cancelled and his
dad has no idea how long they'll now
have to wait i understand there are
at least three other
patients
who need brain surgery pediatric
patients
who will be ahead of him it breaks my
heart to be honest because it's very
difficult
alberta's punishing fourth wave has
forced the cancellation of thousands of
surgeries with every available resource
going towards expanding and staffing
intensive care beds
some of these surgeries can be safely
delayed but not for long things that are
affecting potentially the
the the lifespan of these patients right
when we look at things like cancer
surgeries of course the sooner um that's
managed the better the outcome is it's
why alberta health services says it's
trying to do as many urgent operations
as possible and with the number of covet
patients beginning to stabilize there
are plans to soon perform more cancer
surgeries as well we'll continue to be
cautious
because as we've said before it's a
fragile balance
to ensure we have available icu beds for
anyone who needs one more fragile given
the time of year
last fall thanksgiving weekend marked
the start of alberta's second wave i
want people who are unvaccinated to
understand that their actions
have implications far beyond them
that if they care for their fellow
albertans
they should do the right thing because a
surge in cases linked to indoor
gatherings this year could be more than
alberta's strained health system can
take
heather urex west global news calgary
today the prime minister publicly
addressed his controversial vacation to
tofino b.c on a day to honor indigenous
people
traveling on september 30th was a
mistake
and i regret it
the first national day of truth and
reconciliation was a time for indigenous
people and non-indigenous people alike
to reflect and connect think about the
past but also
focus on the future
indigenous leaders slammed trudeau for
spending the day on the beach rather
than with residential school survivors
trudeau had been asked twice to visit
the site of the former residential
school in kamloops where suspected
unmarked graves were recently discovered
the prime minister says he plans to in
the coming weeks
some news tonight from elections canada
the liberal government has picked up
another seat in quebec incumbent brenda
shanahan will be returning to parliament
after a recount declared her the winner
of chateau gay le call she beat her
block quebec quebecois rival patrick
o'hara by just 12 votes this bumps the
number of seats held by the liberals to
159
just days after being given the position
a senior military officer has been
removed from the job major general peter
dawg will no longer be involved in
reviewing ways to eliminate sexual
misconduct in the canadian forces as our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stephenson
explains daw was only removed after
sexual assault survivors spoke out
i was
stunned and dismayed
to see the media reports
about this
particular role
harsh words for the prime minister for
the country's top brass over the
controversial appointment of major
general peter daw
a decision the military reversed late
tuesday night after public backlash you
said mercedes that it seems as if
the leadership
just doesn't get it
and i think that's true daw has been on
paid leave since may after the cbc
reported he had written a positive
character reference for a convicted sex
offender from his regiment
that man sexually assaulted retired army
captain annelie shimoon in her home
shimoon was blindsided by the decision
to bring daw back in such a sensitive
role my first thought was to all of the
people who would lose even more hope in
the system that would be so devastated
by this decision the vice chief of the
defense staff is acknowledging yet
another significant misstep i recognize
and apologize for the harm this has
caused the release of this news should
have been handled by us with greater
care and consideration
but victims groups say even the apology
is tone deaf they were stunned by the
military's announcement dawg would
commit to restorative engagement
something they had not agreed to now
they've put it onto victims groups to
solve it for them shamoon says she's
heard nothing from the general we don't
know where he's at or what work he's
done also troubling the group it's just
700 says there was no sign in a hastily
scheduled meeting on tuesday that the
vice chief of the defense staff
understood the problem with the
appointment and that she defended daw
she found out he had done
nothing wrong the victims group says
allen defended the appointment saying
she followed the military's process but
survivors say it's precisely that kind
of blind adherence to a problematic
system that is preventing meaningful
change
robin mercedes stephenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes
an ontario teacher has been found not
guilty in the death of a student
nicholas mills oversaw a school canoe
trip to algonquin provincial park in
2017. prosecutors argued he ignored
safety rules and allowed 15-year-old
jeremiah perry to go in the water
without a life jacket today a justice
ruled the teacher's actions fell below
the reasonable standard of care but did
not constitute criminal negligence
when the prime minister announced this
country's climate targets in april
climate activists said it wasn't enough
and now a new government-funded study
shows canada is off the mark which means
a recent promise to achieve net zero in
30 years may need some rethinking eric
sorenson has been combing through the
report
for a large country with an economy that
relies on fossil fuel production
achieving climate targets is still not
coming into view according to a new
report the trottier energy institute
suggests that by 2030 canada is on track
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions just
16 below 2005 levels far short of the
target of 40 to 45 percent set by the
trudeau government this year to get
there the report says canada in part
must transition out of fossil fuel
dependency to energy sources that do not
emit greenhouse gasses and that we're
not doing enough we need to have
investments in those
infrastructures that we don't see yet we
have to reduce our curb our carbon
footprint
it's either we plan it properly or we
suffer the consequences of not doing so
the minister of environment's office
suggests the report's modeling is flawed
that many measures to reduce emissions
are not included in the report measures
such as billions of dollars for home and
building retrofits and to reduce
industrial and vehicle emissions if
little is done all major sectors will
contribute to continuing high emissions
ottawa is sticking to its target at
least 40 percent below 2005 levels in
everything from transportation to energy
production to commercial and residential
buildings by 2050 transportation and
agriculture will still be net emitters
of greenhouse gases but sectors like
electricity by closing fossil fuel
burning plants reliance on biomass
combustion and direct air carbon capture
would balance out and bring canada to
net zero emissions at least that's the
goal if more is required the ndp has the
votes to help the liberals pass new
climate measures we need to make sure
that we hit our targets as a country it
is so critical we are in a climate
emergency and so we are going to be
pushing this government to take bold
action on the climate crisis the
conservatives have set less ambitious
targets and say the liberal promises
can't be taken seriously they have never
made a climate target
they continue to see every year under mr
trudeau our our missions have gone up as
a major oil producing country canada's
commitments will be under intense
scrutiny when the next u.n climate
change summit begins in glasgow in less
than four weeks eric sorensen global
news toronto
a major milestone in the fight against
malaria coming up approval for a shot
that could save thousands of lives
facebook founder mark zuckerberg is
hitting back at the testimony from a
whistleblower the ceo of the social
media network says the accusations
painted a false picture of the company
and claims that facebook puts profits
before people are just not true a day
earlier in front of the u.s senate
former employee francis hagen said
facebook routinely made decisions that
put business interests ahead of user
safety
the world health organization is calling
it a breakthrough for science endorsing
the first vaccine to prevent malaria
it's been 30 years in the making about
800 000 kids in africa received a shot
through a pilot program that started two
years ago in 2019 nearly half a million
people died from malaria mostly in
africa and more than half were kids five
and under when the vaccine was used with
anti-malaria drugs hospitalizations and
deaths involving children dropped by 70
percent
still ahead how the pandemic is carving
out a new career path for some canadians
the covet shutdown allowed a number of
canadians to rethink their jobs asking
questions like do i have a future in
this and can i go back to school for
something else as ann gaviola reports in
her pandemic pivot series there are lots
of opportunities and a labor force in
demand
before the pandemic maggie devito spent
seven years in the restaurant industry
most recently as a bartender in
vancouver's entertainment district when
she was laid off because of kovid she
learned computer coding i really fell in
love with it and the problem solving of
it and just how
big of a world tech is and how
much i could help and do other things
and you're constantly learning in it she
took out a student loan and got a
scholarship to a comprehensive coding
bootcamp after putting in 80-hour weeks
in an intense three-month training
program she was hired as a web developer
one of the most sought after positions
in tech she went from making about 20
dollars an hour to 25 and her future
earning potential looks pretty good yeah
it's been nice
education platform course compare
reports a big boost in people switching
into tech especially among the
underemployed and jobless we've seen a
significant increase in demand for
training in digital skills
with data science web development
digital marketing user experience design
and cyber security leading the way the
greatest demand is for shorter courses
offering flexibility as opposed to
multi-year degrees graduating sooner
means getting hired sooner too it's 95
or more percent of people who secure
relevant work
within six months of graduation
and salaries in the 50 to 60 000 range
the general interest in changing careers
and changing jobs has been profound and
substantial
especially with the emergence of the
tech industry as one of those few
industries that really thrived
recruiters say there was a shortage of
tech workers pre-covered but immigrants
helped fill that gap which wasn't the
case during the pandemic creating an
even bigger need for these skills
a career in tech can take you many
places according to canada's job bank
one in four web developers work for a
non-tech firm in finance retail and even
arts and culture ann gaviola global news
toronto
the pandemic set off a cleaning frenzy
at grocery stores but a new study shows
all that extra disinfection may not be
necessary scientists from the university
of guelph in ontario swapped about a
thousand high contact surfaces in
grocery stores and found none of them
tested positive for cover 19. the team
began their investigation last year
after reports the virus could survive
for hours even days on surfaces as long
as stores enforce regular sanitization
routines and monitor the health of
employees the risk of exposure remains
low
up next the big game hunters that swam
under the radar until now
the whales on the west coast are
riveting revered and of course
researched now a new study is shining
light on a lesser-known variety of
killer whales that are being described
as the big game hunters of the sea as
ross lord tells us that also makes them
ruthless
killer whales or orcas can be as
charismatic as they are powerful but
even though they number roughly 50 000
and are seen and photographed around the
world they can still surprise
researchers there's been so many studies
on them and it's a shock to me that
we're you know
we're still learning so much about them
canadian josh mcinnis teamed with
american researchers to study a
little-known subset of transient killer
whales that roams the pacific ocean
they're within the same population but
they seem to have a different habitat
preferences more
offshore as well as
they seem to you know hunt things like
gray whale calves or elephant seals
unlike some orcas which can seemingly
hug the coastline he says these animals
prefer deep water canyon